I've never met this gentleman but I'm
going to take a controversial figure and
talk about it because I've had three
separate people on his staff now
describe him which is the CEO of
wal-mart and the story goes and I don't
know if it's true or not but the story
goes that he walked in and said hi we're
going to become a highly sensitive green
sustainable corporation and his staff
went into this long explanation of how
he was just wrong it was not their
business model it was not their customer
base they couldn't be if they couldn't
implement it they couldn't sell that
couldn't anything at the end of about an
hour of heated discussion he said this
is a fantastic conversation I am so glad
we've all engaged to this or talk about
it again in two weeks and it took him
over a year and he he moved that
organization to a place where you know
you can argue that whether you like
Walmart or not right but if you look at
a business leader that moved a company
it into a place where it now begins to
make a lot of sense but there was a
vision there there was a commitment to a
goal there was clear leadership right I
that's pretty impressive to me I there
are many people at Intel that i can
highlight equally but i feel it would be
self-serving but just for someone where
we have no business you know walmart is
not a big customer of ours there's no no
you know those there's nothing here but
in that story and having multiple people
on his death tell that story and pretty
much the same way I I believe it pretty
much happened that way
so the first thing is you know you have
a business vision you you kind of know
where you're going you've got a way that
you think that's going to work right you
just imagine trying to do any social
networking sites I'm not so sure that 12
years ago if someone described in me
facebook I would have said that was a
good idea but someone clearly had a
leader a leader position there so the
first thing is a business vision that
matters the second of all you have to be
willing to take informed risks and nu
and and I don't know if that really
means being a visionary but it certainly
means that you have to you have to have
a pretty good sense for how to do it
right what we have found and leadership
is kind of edgy and the reason I say
that is because there's some people that
have been very effective leaders over
the years that are really pretty
despicable people and we always want to
talk about leadership in terms of the
people that we admire and respect but
unfortunately there have been some
pretty corrupt and evil leaders in the
world that I've proven to be very very
strong leaders so I don't want to paint
this it into into into that form but in
in assuming ethical business leadership
under those those constraints right
you've got to understand the business
first and foremost you have to be able
to then articulate that and paint a
vision for where you're trying to go and
then third of all in top in my opinion
then you've got to be able to build a
series a series of trusting
relationships with the people that that
have to be with you because you can
forgive an awful lot of things if you
trust the person if you if if you missed
the trust at least in the business
setting I don't think you got there so
if i look at at least for what i try to
emulate those would be the three and
then and then of course then you need
you know good governance and there's a
whole series of operational issues that
are required if you want to actually
make it successful but i think when the
leadership aspect it would be
hi I think we should go blank and you
you think about that for a while and you
play with it with your mind and maybe
you talk to one or two people about it
and they certainly assure you that
you're wrong and then you then go okay
well then I'm going to modify a little
bit you come back to them and when they
stop saying vehemently know then you
figure that you must be pretty close and
then you try to go write a group of
people to say hi I want us to consider
this and then you start doing that
process I face that every day I'm trying
to move the status quo and sometimes of
course they realize there are other
people at Intel who would tell you every
day they try to move me so it's not a
matter that I'm this great person trying
to move the corporation and others or
not I think of mr. Otellini very clear
on the fact that he's the CEO and I'm
not and he is and I'm not so at
different levels we're all working the
same issue but but each time you're
trying to form a consensus you're trying
to get people to see the world
differently than they see it today and
you're trying to paint that that new
vision is better than where we are today
and then and then you proceed with your
data